Necesitamos ser parte de una comunidad para sobrevivir.
Nacemos tan indefensos
que necesitamos del cuidado de otros hasta cerca de los 10 años de edad,
y así nuestro cerebro evoluciona hacia la comida.
Necesitamos estar en esa comunidad.
En definitiva, me guste o no,
al no haber sido invitado a la boda de mi amigo,
mi cerebro reptiliano genera la misma respuesta
que si me fueran a expulsar de la comunidad.
De este modo, la ciencia explica muy bien
por qué las situaciones justas son buenas
y por qué las injustas nos ponen a la defensiva.
Pero la ciencia muestra también que, en un entorno justo,
no sólo queremos ser el cuadrado,
sino que tendemos a ser el cuadrado,
y esto hace que otras personas sean, a la vez, justas.
Así se crea un bello círculo de justicia.
Pero cuando empezamos a ser justos desde el comienzo,
una sola gota de injusticia contamina la piscina entera
y, lamentablemente, hay muchas otras gotas en esa piscina.
Nuestro esfuerzo, entonces, debe ser el de filtrar
las situaciones de injusticia cuanto más sea posible,
en todos los ámbitos, empezando por la comunidad, la empresa.
Este tema me preocupa particularmente,
porque estoy a cargo de un equipo de 3000 personas excelentes,
y la diferencia entre 3000 empleados felices y motivados,
que trabajan en equipo,
y 3000 personas que miran su reloj, lo es todo.
Por eso, lo primero que trato de hacer en mi cruzada por la justicia
(Risas)
es tratar de ponerme fuera de la ecuación.
Esto significa tomar conciencia de mis propios prejuicios.
Por ejemplo, me encanta la gente que dice que sí
a lo que yo sugiero.
(Risas)
Pero eso no es bueno para la empresa,
ni tampoco para los que tienen otras ideas.
Por eso intentamos promover activamente
una cultura de diversidad de opiniones y de personalidades.
La segunda medida es más procedimental.
Estudiamos las reglas, los procesos, los sistemas en la compañia,
los que usamos para tomar decisiones y asignar recursos,
y tratamos de evitar lo que no está claro,
no es racional o no tiene sentido,
e intentamos solucionar todo lo que esté restringiendo
la transferencia de información dentro de la empresa.
Luego analizamos la cultura y la motivación por las mismas razones.
Pero el punto es que, independientemente de lo minuciosos que seamos
en analizar las reglas, los procesos, los sistemas —que es necesario hacer—,
nunca estaremos haciendo lo suficiente
para llegar a la verdadera esencia del sentido de justicia.
Esto es porque el último tramo de la justicia requiere algo más.
Tiene que ver con las emociones,
con las necesidades de las personas,
con lo que les pasa en la vida privada,
con lo que la sociedad necesita.
Estas son todas preguntas y elementos
difíciles de representar en una hoja de cálculo, en un algoritmo.
Es muy difícil hacerlas parte de nuestra decisión racional.
Pero si no las tenemos en cuenta, dejaremos pasar puntos claves,
y es posible que el resultado se interprete como injusto.
Debemos entonces verificar nuestras decisiones
con el centro de justicia activado.
¿Es correcto que esta persona obtenga el empleo que realmente desea?
¿Corresponde despedir a esta persona?
¿Es correcto cobrar tanto por este producto?
Estas son preguntas difíciles.
Pero si nos tomamos el tiempo para preguntarnos
si la respuesta racional es la correcta ...
todos sabemos, en el fondo, cuál es la respuesta.
Lo sabemos desde bebés.
Y saber cuál es la respuesta correcta
es muy bueno a la hora de tomar decisiones.
Y si usamos el corazón,
—que es la clave para sacar lo mejor de la gente,
porque presienten cuando les importamos—,
y si demostramos que nos importan, dejarán atrás sus miedos
y vendrán a trabajar con la versión real de sí mismos.
En definitiva, si la justicia es una piedra angular en la vida,
¿por qué los líderes no la toman como prioridad?
¿No sería maravilloso trabajar en una empresa que sea más justa?
¿No sería fantástico tener colegas y jefes que fueran seleccionados y capacitados
en base a su sentido de justicia y a su personalidad
y no por su desempeño en el examen de aptitudes empresariales GMAT,
que tiene ya 60 años?
¿No sería bueno poder golpear la puerta de un director de justicia?
Lo lograremos, pero ¿por qué no está ocurriendo ahora?
En parte, es por inercia.
En parte, porque no siempre es fácil ser justos.
Requiere juicio y riesgo.
Perforar aquel octavo pozo fue arriesgado.
Ascender a aquel empleado
que no había completado su educación secundaria fue un riesgo.
Construir aquella fábrica de queso en Ecuador fue un riesgo.
Pero ser justos es un riesgo que vale la pena correr,
por eso deberíamos preguntarnos,
¿dónde podemos asumir este riesgo?
¿Dónde podemos avanzar un poco más,
ir más allá de lo racional y hacer lo correcto?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)